Exactly.
We'll be fine.
I don't know, wouldn't it be crazy if our story included, like, minks?
No, that's our thing. I think it's totally good.
For the Red Wolves,
the prompt is thus.
An enchanted mirror
is showing everyone
a different version of reality.
You must figure out what's true
before someone gets damaged.
Wow.
Begin!
That's high tension.
Power's going home.
He's cooked, chat. He's cooked.
Ricky, this is Power's
D&D arc.
This is where it starts.
It's gotta start somewhere.
The ripped shirt.
That's what it was.
Thank you.
It's killing me.
It's so hard to guess. Is it Macarena?
Is it Brown Eyed Peas?
Is it Macarena?
What a crazy playlist.
It's so funny. Oh my god.
Like, on the way here, I looked up medieval
on Spotify, and it came up, and I was like,
I was like, what?
I was like, who made this? It's insane.
Every song. People who are passionate about it.
I know. They love it.
I'm gonna be the one to write the medieval version.
I'm gonna do it.
And more boldly, someone said that about the Macarena.
And they did it.
And they did it perfectly.
I mean, I could have done it better.
I know.
It's so good.
You have 25 seconds,
peasants.
Would you like to gather any
props, perhaps?
What?